the size of space is so staggeringly
enormous
that it is quite impossible for the
human mind to grasp it
also vast expanses of space will for the
most part
never be explored and clearly defined
even though in the past several
millennia man has learned to analyze the
build up of the nearest galaxies
there still remain areas in the cosmos
which are practically impossible to
observe
let alone actually reach one of these
areas is intergalactic space
a mysterious part of the universe lying
hundreds of thousands of light years
away
in complete darkness
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
predictably enough the term
intergalactic space is generally used to
refer to parts of space between galaxies
it is believed that certain portions of
these areas are practically devoid of
any matter
which makes the composition quite close
to that of absolute vacuum
with some of its areas stretching as far
as millions of light years in all
directions
intergalactic space is for the most part
filled with ionized gas
generally this gas is hot hydrogen whose
density here
is 10 times less than that in
interstellar environment
namely less than one atom to one cubic
decimeter
there are also heavier elements to be
found here as well
like carbon oxygen and silicon
some part of intergalactic gas is
concentrated in clouds differing from
each other very much
in terms of density and temperature
interestingly
the chemical composition of their gas is
diverse
it may contain atoms of hydrogen helium
carbon nitrogen oxygen sulfur
and various metals it is this gas that
more likely than not
feeds stellar formations in all galaxies
there are also much larger objects to be
found in intergalactic space
for example stars were spotted there
quite recently
the total number of intergalactic stars
in the observable universe may reach
several trillion within the milky way
alone
around 650 of these rogue stars have
been pinpointed so far
as a rule intergalactic matter doesn't
emit any light
and is mostly invisible to the potential
observer that is why its discovery was
actually made by pure chance
it all started with quasars which were
discovered in the 1960s
very soon scientists noticed that the
light from the quasars had certain
missing pieces in some spectra
these particles were absorbed by
something in between
quasars and astronomers telescopes it
later transpired that this invisible
matter was the gas of the intergalactic
medium
the igm in the decades that followed
vast accumulations and filaments of gas
and heavier elements were discovered in
intergalactic space
and even though at first glance it
appears to be empty
its dimensions are so mind-blowing that
there must be more matter
evenly distributed around it than there
is mata
in all the galaxies of the observable
universe combined
it is safe to assume that some part of
intergalactic gas has been left out
there after the hypothetical big bang
still as there are heavier elements in
its composition it may only mean that
many of these elements used to be part
of interstellar dust
lost by other galaxies
intergalactic gas actually plays an
important role in the process of the
universe's evolution
under the influence of a galaxy's
gravitational pull
gas is gradually sucked into galaxies at
the rate of one solar mass a year
which is quite close to the rate of star
formation in the disk of the milky way
apart from that matter exchange among
all galaxies occurs thanks to this
process
the point is that stars in a given area
of the universe collapse and release
part of their matter in intergalactic
space
having been released the mata becomes
part of intergalactic gas
and so later takes part in the processes
of star formation in other galaxies
consequently star formation in galaxies
will not stop
while there is still intergalactic gas
around pulled by gravity
a substantial portion of intergalactic
gas is matter remaining after
supernovae which is why temperatures in
some areas of intergalactic environments
are extremely high
sometimes reaching as much as several
million degrees celsius
the high temperature of some areas may
also be accounted for by electromagnetic
radiation
emitted by intergalactic black holes
following matter accretion on their
surfaces
or else by powerful streams of energy
emitted by still more massive black
holes
intergalactic gas plays the role of raw
material in star formation
while intergalactic space is some sort
of a tank used for its storage
the mechanism of intergalactic gas
recirculation hasn't been studied deeply
enough
first of all because unlike galaxies
which are bright and easily seen
this gas emits no light to speak of
in their attempt to study this
phenomenon astronomers have devised
supercomputer foggy foggy models the
patterns of intergalactic gas movements
and it is possible to observe how gas
traveled around galaxies
in the course of 13 billion years most
of this matter is carried to
intergalactic environment by stellar
wind
that is thanks to the process of mata
flow from stars to areas beyond their
galaxies
it should be mentioned that this occurs
when particles in a star's atmosphere
accelerate to speeds exceeding the
escape velocity of this star
stellar wind is crucial for stellar
evolution
as a result of this process the mass of
a star diminishes
and the intensity of this process has a
direct impact on this particular star's
lifespan
also stellar wind is capable of carrying
matter
enormous distances through space away
from its departure point as it were
moreover it may have an impact on matter
around rounded by sharing
some of its kinetic energy results of
this process may be clearly observed in
the shapes of some galaxies or nebulae
for instance the emission nebula ngc
nicknamed bubble assumed its shape as a
result of this
process and in the case of galaxy m82
also known as the cigar galaxy we can
observe how stellar wind from a great
number of stars
caused clearly seen matter rejections
from the galaxy
apart from the debris left over from
supernovae there is also intergalactic
dust to be found in this environment
today it is posited that it is
intergalactic dust that is to blame for
jinxing estimations of distances on the
intergalactic scale
for example when supernovae quasars or
other galaxies are being observed
among its many properties it is capable
of forming clouds
by 1980 four such nebulae had been
pinpointed within several megapass sects
from the milky way
as for intergalactic stars they are
rather difficult to detect and explore
some of them have been spotted in the
x-ray spectrum with the help of the
chandra x-ray observatory
many of them are binary systems made up
of one regular star as one component
and one compact heavy object like a
black hole is the other
when such celestial bodies lie close to
each other
the more massive component attracts
matter from the regular star
while flowing to its new host mata
spirals away from its source to form an
accretion disk
disc compresses and heats up to
extremely high temperatures
and as a result it does not simply
become luminescent
but starts emitting x-rays it is next to
impossible to spot most objects of this
kind using regular telescopes
meanwhile rogue stars inhabiting voids
may eventually prove to be quite a
common thing
rather than something extraordinary and
perhaps about
half of starlight is actually emitted by
stars lying beyond the boundaries of
galaxies
it is hard to tell how big their number
may be
and today it is barely possible to
imagine that man will ever visit
those places objects lurking in those
mysterious parts of space
may be of considerable interest to
science
and who knows perhaps it is
intergalactic space that will be scanned
with all telescopes by scientists
in a few centuries time still for now
this environment is just another mystery
of the universe
quite beyond our reach at this point it
is places like this that really thwart
our ambition to completely figure out
space
and its properties and it is places like
this that drive us to take
keen interest in how it all works
[Music]
you